if i was black probably wouldn't but
anyone who's white cause that slavery
would honestly always be on my mind if i
was black probably wouldn't ever want to
drive because if police pull me over i
might go around and die if i was black i
won't lie i'd be scared to walk at night
oh
i this is not where i thought this was
going i'm not gonna lie to you the
neighborhood is tripping like i'm out
committing crimes i be pissed at all
these cracker rappers singing about my
life stole my music store my style give
it back it is
i just wasn't expecting this back just
look at the facts we don't stand a
chance one in three is locked away over
half don't know they dead see white
privilege and a money thing but it's
white people who are running things
y'all benefit from your coloring my
pigment produce suffering is all white
white lies white houses white guys
whitewashing my brothers my sisters my
culture while i'm watching if i was
i feel so uncomfortable
they say racism made me racist and i am
not the one to blame hey y'all won't say
it to my face in the circles you feel
safe y'all been using words they made
for us when we were slaves hey hey wait
whoa i know that was long ago if i was
black i'd want my reparation money paid
if i was black i'd say the police i'd
take the whole plan not the roads in
these sheets if i was
okay i have a question the reparations
things i've thought about this
hypothetically let's say they did
reparations
i'm irish right i came from like ireland
[Music]
if i was black probably wouldn't ever do
my taxes why support a government to
persecute my blackness or pay the wage
of law enforcement putting us in caskets
okay i'm not gonna lie to you guys
i hear what he's saying but you should
really do your taxes
you i there are people that go to jail
for a long time for not doing your tact
like you don't
don't listen to that do your taxes or
help to build the prisons that we
trapped in if i was black i'd be mad
people glorify the trap while we dying
every day fighting for everything we
have it ain't diamond changing racks
this a systematic plan they put us in
the ghetto gave us hiv and crack if i
was black i'd hate america appropriate
my character and sell it to caucasians
who wish they were from my area if i was
black i wouldn't give a [ __ ] about the
greater good my grandma can't afford a
wreck or gentrified our neighborhood our
lives matter so stupid y'all hijacking
our movement black lives matter cause we
losing innocent youth the police
shootings if i was black the only role
models i'm shown is the rich black
rappers pushing guns and drugs and hoes
yeah hey y'all won't say it too
look
that's a little racist there are
definitely other role models like
like will smith he doesn't do any of
that that's that's a little racist to me
i mean
i don't i don't want to say it but my
face in the circles you feel safe y'all
been using words they made for us when
we were slaves hey hey wait whoa i know
that was long ago if i was black i'd
want my reparation why'd you guys do
this to me why'd you do this to me
[Music]
if i was black i would load all my teeth
so if you think i'm broke you will know
when i speak
if i was black it's my face on a t ryb
underneath or my name extra free
if i was black i would die in these
streets just but speaking my mind
because
[Music]
okay
what is going on
with that guy's mouth i was like 11
tried to take me down cindy's just
saying like appropriation isn't okay
fist in the air i would stay in my
ground if i was black i'd say the police
[Music]
okay
i got i got the idea
i'm
uh